when the world comes down on you the
couple times that it has either for the
Randy Moss thing or for the bachelor way
he made a call [ __ ] moss did like a
mock mooning of the crowd after he
scored and in Green Bay oh yeah and and
Joe said it was disgusting yeah that is
disgusting everybody get his [ __ ]
head out of his ass he's always so
buttoned up you know I mean so that fed
the idea that I'm this like nerd who can
a nerdy prude play-by-play guy which
whatever I feel is disgusting what he
did or the fact that just enough with
these guys doing this new me you know
I've done games where tio Terrell Owens
grab the pom-poms in it you know that
stuff's funny I thought to paying fans
in a playoff game to go to the fans
turn your you know back side to them and
fake shimmying your pants down then go
to the goalposts and kind of do the same
thing I was like come on that's I think
you need to be better than that Randy
and I are great I saw him last night
took a picture with him and put it on
Twitter you know like we're taking this
act on the road but you know yeah I got
a lot of crap for that it's still your
number one most viewed YouTube thing
thank God
that's number one yeah there it is right
there that's funny taking our act on the
road but so the other the other thing
that they came down on you for was
saying that you're just as likely to
watch The Bachelor as you are a baseball
game yeah and that's true that's true
today but Mike Witt like I think Skip
Bayless was like going nuts on you after
that one wasn't you like calling for
your job and stuff and when you have
people who are fellow like broadcasters
do you not like for instance comedians
don't really trash other comedians
because it's like there's a good reason
to you right there's kind of a bit of a
brotherhood so when you're watching skip
bayless or you like we skip like I [ __ ]
is your prize I don't care what he said
then or now yeah and and I some of that
stuff is just sensational you know I'm
gonna take a crazy you're gonna I'm
gonna call for this guy's job I mean it
went no it was he joking when he said it
or did he really mean it no he's like
this is Jack bucks son and he says he
might
was it was Colin Cowherd asked me and he
said you know are you watching games
every night and you know going to bed
and watching the West Coast games and I
was like I I have a wife I have
daughters I'm watching The Bachelor I'm
you know cooking dinner I'm you know I I
read and and I'm up on what I need to be
up on but I have a life I'm not a sports
nerd right and nothing against it but
that's just I'm feel like there's more
to life than just one thing sports yeah
and he got mad at you and thought you
should be fired for what for what I mean
that yeah there was always an outrageous
every night yeah here's the funny part
of that I care less about what he or
somebody like him would think of me than
I do the random guy on Twitter really
probably yeah because you know he's
probably stationed Eliza he's you know
or awful announcing does something
that's just clickbait it's just I don't
care about that stuff but it's it's the
random guy that that has a clever thing
that it's like good that guys because
that guy is not confirming something
that you feel deep down some [ __ ]
saying you should be fired shut up
but someone going you stinks like oh god
they know